happens does it happen it does happen it
does happen I'm usually like right on it
am I gonna but usually it's not gonna
lose my eyesight
[Music]
[Applause]
hey what's going on and happy holidays
hot ones fans this is Sean Evans coming
at you from the very cozy and very real
hot ones Fireside and it's time for the
spiciest annual tradition of them all
the hot ones holiday Extravaganza now if
you know me I'm a Sentimental guy
especially during the holidays I
remember TGIF the Family Matters holiday
special and bring a tear to my eyes you
know just the other day I watched home
alone and then I watched Home Alone 2
just to get in the holiday spirit so the
idea that the hot ones holiday
Extravaganza could be a part of your
holiday tradition it means the world to
us here at the show and all we ask in
return you know in exchange for me
eating the bomb like 40 times a year
every year of basically my adult life
all we ask is that if you're capable
please please consider a donation to our
charity partner common threads as we
work together to help them achieve their
holiday fundraising goals common threads
is committed to providing children and
families with Hands-On cooking and
nutrition education class classes that
strengthen communities by promoting
healthy cooking healthy eating and the
celebration of culture
to help us in supporting this amazing
organization all you need to do click
that donate button in this corner or in
that corner but I'm pretty sure it's
this corner this corner right here hit
that donate button help us support
common threads last year Gordon Ramsay
busted out his Santa sack of tricks and
you guys busted open your wallets we
raised close to a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars can we do that again
this year I hope so but either way we
have a rollicking run of show for you
from everyone here at the first we Feast
family Jesus Trejo is taste testing
classic holiday dishes with the kids of
common threads George Nicole and Alvin
have got leftover sandwich hacks that
even a kitchen dummy like me can pull
off camera guy Bill is back in his
holiday finery to present the second
annual hot ones Awards and to close
things out I know you peeped it in the
thumbnail baby Will Ferrell is back for
a second go-round with the wings of
death stay tuned to find out if milk was
a bad choice but in the meantime we head
over to Los Angeles and Tacos con Toto
host Jesus Trail who's hanging out with
his young gang of budding food critics
Jesus take it away
happy holidays everybody this is
Trejo
I love to do during the holiday season
is a little three-letter word starts
with an e ends with a T there's a little
a in the middle
eat I love to eat and here with me today
to help me eat are some very special
friends
[Music]
are we shy
a little yeah I get it what is your name
and where are you from my name is Omar
and I'm and I'm from cudahaste Cudahy in
the house my name is Emma and I'm nine
years old Emma nine years old where you
from
[Music]
um
from L.A Yeah Yeah from L.A well welcome
Emma yeah
Olivia from L.A Olivia from L.A
I'm Vincent I'm 10 years old and I am
from Atwater Los Angeles
and with that we're gonna go try some
amazing holiday foods from around the
world let's go
[Music]
tell me what you think as soon as you
taste it what does this remind you of
for me it reminds me of a Cinnabon oh if
they start making Cinnabon smoothies I
am there would you drink like a cinnamon
roll smoothie oh what happened what
happened the cinnamon went to my eye oh
no are you okay yeah I'm okay okay okay
these are
you are looking at moon cakes it's a
Chinese pastry filled with sweets and
it's super popular during the mid-autumn
festival look if you look at the full
cookie what do you think that is right
there I see a blossom tree blossom tree
I kind of see a rabbit a tree on the
moon this outer part kind of feels like
it feels like dried up Play-Doh but
tastes like bread yeah I love the symbol
you like the round shape what it
symbolizes it's togetherness you guys
like being together yeah yes yeah group
hug oh group hug my goodness group hug
that fell apart really good that was
anything but togetherness right there
that was separateness
you guys want to try it no yeah all
right
all right three two one get in there oh
my God it tastes like you haven't tasted
it
okay
you're not gonna try it no
can I pass me a napkin oh yeah we got a
napkin right here there you go anyone
need a napkin it smells like raisins
actually because it is made with raisins
raisins and dried fruit oh no Christmas
pudding you guys
what do you think it is uh a weird
sandwich what you're looking at right
now is a Ethiopian dish called dorawat
basically what this is is a Savory stew
the tortilla part of it that we were
talking about that's called in German
basically what you do is you open it up
like a little gift
we don't need this we're going to put
that right here and you rip a little bit
of this and you go in you slap it down
you basically pinch it what what's that
is this an avocado no it's not an
avocado that's an egg that's a
hard-boiled egg it's very spicy it's
very spicy spicy very spicy too okay if
you hold it up to the light you can see
all the little holes
like the consistency the inside of it
does look like molar you're right that's
a that's a good call fist bump Boom the
little holes in the tortilla reminds me
of SpongeBob oh they remind you of
SpongeBob right there SpongeBob
SquarePants on to the next
what do you think is in this little box
orange chicken rice and my Amazon
package
your Amazon bag this next dish is eaten
during New Year's in Japan you guys
ready yeah three two one
whoa the different food items are meant
to represent Prosperity good fortune and
Health it's so fancy it's fancy right
it's called a Bento Box who likes
Abalone never heard of it yeah me either
I I said it pretty confidently I don't
know what Abalone Abalone that's why you
know I haven't had it because I called
it Abalone and it's actually Abalone
let's make a promise that we're gonna
try at least one thing in the Bento Box
okay which is one thing what is the
prettiest thing you see in there
oh the salmon eggs the salmon eggs all
right what about you Omar shrimp shrimp
that's the prettiest thing and you
kissed it try naturally
[Music]
I'll give you props for trying it that's
really cool
these are strawberry and pineapple
tamales
have you had them before Omar nope Omar
talk to me what's going on yes it's
because I like regular tamales so what
is the regular tamale can you describe
it for me chickeny
is so smooth or the chickening flavor
you want to try the pineapple one the
pineapple one has a has raisins in it
pineapple has raisin that's a great
thing no no okay tamales
[Music]
you guys we got through that how do you
guys feel
good give yourself a big round of
applause
that was really cool I really enjoy
eating with you guys I really felt like
we learned a lot about other cultures
and how they celebrate you know the
holiday season happy holidays
shot
R.I.P to Christmas pudding but a huge
shout out to Omar Olivia Vincent and
Emma Jesus looks like we might have some
future stand-ups on our hands and again
if you would like to help these amazing
kids and their families again please
please please if you're able consider a
donation to Common threads and with that
out of the way it is time to move on in
the show where we check in with the
first we Feast hosts of The Burger show
Burger scholar sessions and pizza wars
as they make the ultimate leftover
sandwich if there's anyone I can count
on to bring in the holiday spirit it is
George moats George what you got cooking
over there I feel like I can smell it
from here
thanks Sean happy holidays everyone as
you know I'm someone who loves tradition
but I love food and in the motels
it's the hardest working button in the
show business
and in the moat's household during the
holidays that means it's time for a very
special leftover sandwich we're gonna
make a turkey hash sandwich
a turkey ass sandwich dark meat dark
meat is amazing because it has flavor
tons of flavor in here I love this
sandwich I love this sandwich okay you
ready to cook let's do this this recipe
actually comes from good friend of mine
and Michelin starred Chef Brad Farmery
so this is a sandwich with a pedigree
first you start by making the hash you
gotta make the hash first it takes a
while I'm not gonna lie to you it might
take a while but it's absolutely worth
it take the skin off the legs pull the
meat off the legs and then braise it on
a stovetop for about 90 minutes in
chicken stock a little bit of soy sauce
I threw some thyme in there which is
really good also you end up with this
this looks like looks like pulled pork
right
oh
that's good
oh
whoa what I'm gonna do is take some good
crusty bread
and toast it up
I like leftovers because you're not
wasting food
do your part people eat leftovers
very important Mayo both sides
turkey hash on there first the hash
you've got mashed potatoes oh green bean
casserole sure get some green in there
you had stuffing in your bird oh how
about that too
um
Gotta Have gravy
on a holiday leftover sandwich I was
gonna have a little bit of hot sauce in
there give it a little kick in the pants
don't forget the slice of canned
cranberry
um
Touch of sweetness
and look at that
[Music]
oh
it's supposed to be sloppy it's okay oh
oh God
oh
wow
happy holidays to me
don't forget to hit that donation button
take it away Alvin
happy holidays y'all it's your boy Alvin
kailan and today we're making my
favorite holiday leftover sandwich we
have crispy Pata
King's Hawaiian bread and everything
else that we have in a Filipino
refrigerator that's gonna make an
ultimate yummy sandwich
so we're gonna start off
with Crispy Pata which is usually pork
leg sometimes pork knuckle you see this
like huge piece of skin you gotta you
have to guard dearly with your life
because you have that one Uncle who will
look at it and steal it off your plate
if you're not looking shout out to you
Nester so I'm gonna throw this onto the
griddle skin is re-crisped
we'll put this on the side add some
cucumber onions chive parsley sugar a
little bit of soy sauce my favorite
calamansi juice this is going to add
some some twang extra virgin olive oil
just to like amp up the anxiousness
give it a nice mix oh yeah look at this
we'll set this aside and then we'll
start with our bread so you want to
toast this until it's nice and brown
pull this off we're going to melt some
of this Adam cheese
they used to give this to us as gifts
and as a child I really never
appreciated it because who the hell
wants cheese for Christmas we'll throw
our Bread on top of that
grab your plate Wham wow
we grab this beautiful
crispy Pata pulled pork I could hear my
mom
in the background going don't forget
your vegetables and there's the
vegetables mom remember that skin that
Uncle Nester did not take
we put it on top Wham look at that
crispy pork Pata sandwich
oh mistletoe is back
[Music]
this is so good there it is crispy pasta
sandwich parole
techno lights
I'm feeling all kinds of holidays Nicole
take it away
[Music]
thanks Alvin and happy holidays
Daisy in my house when I think of
holiday leftovers it makes me think of
one thing and one thing only Jamaican
corned beef and cabbage for those who
don't know Jamaican corned beef and
cabbage is also called bully beef and
cabbage and it's a staple in the
Jamaican household and you know what it
makes for an incredible leftover
sandwich especially on some Jamaican
Hondo bread and that's what we're gonna
do today okay so I'm gonna take my bread
and the trick here is I'm gonna get
killed by my mom but you know I'm greedy
I want the Big Slice of the bread so I'm
going straight for the middle
and look at that see it's super dense
but it's also super soft so
traditionally all you need corned beef
and cabbage hard door bread you're all
set but me you know I like to Jazz
things up a little differently you know
it goes good with mustard and next the
star of the show the Jamaican corned
beef and cabbage so when you couldn't
get the real Prime cuts of beef you
would get the corned beef in a can and
you would make do with it it's like a
struggle food but we don't struggle no
more because now instead of just putting
one can we put two cans we took two cans
mind blown and the way that you make
this is super easy all you have to do is
stew down some cabbage some onions you
know some peppers some tomato when I
smell this I think of my childhood when
my mother would make this so I would
just stand by wait for my mother to move
to the side and I snatch some hot right
out the pot so now you need some swiss
cheese so what's next on here I'm gonna
put some crunchy bacon down and then I'm
gonna add some tomatoes and then the
last thing is the cool Iceberg shredded
lettuce
and then we're gonna top it
Booyah what's up I'm gonna cut it right
down the middle just like they would do
with cat's Deli you know what I'm saying
you know what I'm saying
look at that baby right there
[Music]
so the corned beef and cabbage is nice
and juicy we got the Swiss cheese the
ice cold lettuce the bacon is slapping
all right guys thanks for joining us but
most importantly make sure you hit that
donation button it really counts all
right that's it for me back to you Sean
wow those sandwiches look delicious to
The Culinary team at first we Feast you
guys never cease to amaze the only thing
that I ask is if you ask me to be on
your shows in the coming years maybe we
can just eat like normal food not
everything has to be spicy George
sometimes I just won an Oklahoma fried
onion burger like without the last dab
can I just have like a normal Pizza does
it have to be a spicy pizza but anyways
I digress you know here on hot ones we
have a lot of Emmy Award winners a lot
of Grammy Award winners Tony Award
winners Oscar award winners but do you
know it's an even more exclusive Club
the hot ones Award winners and it is
that time I'm on pins and needles and
the only difference between our award
show and the other ones we don't have
some price Waterhouse Cooper audit for
the selection process it's just a lot of
love and a lot of appreciation for the
people who've taken on the hot ones
Gauntlet and it is time to pass the
reins over to our very illustrious hosts
camera guy Bill with the hot ones 2022
Awards
it's the hot ones Awards we're here for
year two I don't know about you but I'm
ready for the hot ones Awards
they'll be celebrities golden amenities
at the hot ones Awards
Sean welcome one and all to the 2022 hot
ones award show I am so incredibly happy
to be back hosting for what is sure to
be an unforgettable show it feels like
we were just here celebrating last
year's winners can you believe it I sure
can't so much has happened so many hot
ones episodes so many memes and lots of
cameras being operated wink the hot ones
Academy is back at it again they've
taken no days off and here we are ready
to Crown the most award-worthy moments
of 2022. let's get to our first award
you know what's harder than eating nine
Wings eating ten and then still being
asked to jump through one final hoop
even after the last dab begins to melt
your brain and set your tunnel Blaze
when cold to Arms these nominees Rose to
the challenge and they all deserve some
recognition for that here are the
nominees for this year's Best Wing 10
moment
post Malone vs Sean Evans water Pond
Bear Grylls eating crickets and worms
Neil Patrick Harris's magic trick and
the winner is
Bear Grylls congratulations bear
hey guys the holiday Extravaganza Best
Wing moment what an honor thank you all
so much uh Sean uh this was a really
special one for me you and your crew uh
such gems so thank you uh have an
amazing holiday
I've only just recovered
well after a wingten moment like that
you sure deserve some hibernation time
bear from the iconic Shack face to look
at us look at us who would have thought
not me hot wings has launched a thousand
memes because let's face it seeing how
celebrities handle themselves while
eating some of the hottest sauces on the
planet is always entertaining with that
in mind here are the nominees for 2022's
best reactions Millie Bobby Brown
Daniel Kalua
Kid Cudi
and the winner is
Kid Cudi congrats Mr Cuddy yo I want to
say thank you so so much for this award
I've been a fan of hot ones for a minute
you know you guys been seeing me on
Twitter talking about it we've been
planning this for a couple years and you
know I just wanted to be memorable just
wanted to have some funny moments want
to make you guys laugh
so uh here we are I guess I did the job
uh Sean holla at me all right we gotta
do round two next switch up some sauces
all right give me a little test
peace and love
wow those shirt were some reactions well
some guests spitting buckets and run
laps around the table others are Stone
Cold Killers who appear to be completely
unaffected by the Scoville Onslaught
this next award goes to the person who
took on all 10 wins and didn't bat an
eye a true champion that deserves
recognition for making it look easy this
was an incredibly tough category because
we've had some true badasses in the hot
one seat here are the nominees for Wing
Warrior
David Blaine
lizzo
Courtney Cox
and the winner is
David Blaine congrats Mr Blaine this hot
ones award is just so meaningful to me
and it's somebody that knows a little
bit now about hot sauce I mean
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you hot ones well that sure was
magical Mr Blaine every now and then we
have a guest who comes to the show and
leaves a lasting impression on everyone
an infectious presence and personality
that captivates the audience in ways we
didn't know possible sometimes it's the
way they tell a story sometimes it's
life advice and other times it's
overcoming the bomb these are the
nominees for the most inspiring
Queen Latifah
Viola Davis
Andrew Callahan
and the winner is
Viola Davis congrats Miss Davis
I have been preparing for this for my
entire life by sucking on Bones sucking
the marrow out of Bones basically eating
a lot of hot wings and chewing with my
mouth open
so thank you hot ones holiday
extravagant Extravaganza 2022 most
inspiring thank you Sean for literally
giving the best interview with the best
chicken wings and then I'm receiving
this award for doing something that was
just
fun
so thank you
inspiring indeed Miss Davis keeping the
inspiration going it's time for the hot
ones Lifetime Achievement Award this
award goes to a person who has given us
so much quality content over the years
from giving Sean his first ever Carolina
Reaper to the most scoville-laced hot
ones episode of all time and who could
forget that Infamous horse and carriage
ride through Central Park this man is an
international phenomenon when it comes
to spice and we at hot ones are so proud
to know him your 2022 hot one's Lifetime
Achievement recipient chilly Klaus
I'm overwhelmed a lifetime achievement
from you guys on hot ones thank you and
of course thank you to my spice brother
Sean Evans I love you man but maybe most
important thank you to all the spice
Lords from all over the world 10 years
ago no one cared about hot sauce or
spicy food
and today we are millions
cheers from Denmark and of course
my Scandinavian cousins
well there you have it spice Lords
another hot ones Awards in the books
this has been a absolute blast thank you
to all our winners and nominees for
giving us these Great Moments and for
coming on our show oh wait there's one
final award that's weird because I'm
reading off the teleprompter ladies and
gentlemen it's the holiday spirit award
I know who that goes to and I think you
do too spoiler alert it's in the
thumbnail ladies and gentlemen back for
round two versus the wings of death our
grand finale to the holiday extravaganza
the elf himself Will Ferrell
foreign
hey what's going on and happy holidays
hot ones fans it's that time the
culmination the grand finale of our hot
ones holiday Extravaganza and I could
not be more excited to once again be
sitting across the table from Will
Ferrell for decades he's been one of
Hollywood's most prolific and enduring
comedic actors from the Saturday Night
Live stage to movies like Anchorman oh
stepbrothers and many many more and on
that note you can catch them starting
alongside Ryan Reynolds in the Christmas
themed musical comedy spirited which is
currently streaming on Apple TV plus
Will Ferrell welcome back to the show
thank you so much I love the little elf
hats just for you the red carpet
treatment amazing amazing what's going
through your head as you prepare to take
on The Gauntlet a second time
yeah I think it's a little bit like
childbirth
um
the first time I did the show
labor was terrible I was like never
gonna do it again but then the feedback
was so amazing this beautiful baby of
feedback and and I didn't remember the
pain anymore and now I'm back here to
make another baby with you let's make a
baby well let's was that a good analogy
was that a good summation yeah thread
the needle you thread the needle right
there well and one last time if you're
able please consider a donation to
Common threads it means the world to us
here at hot ones for the kids and the
families will are you ready to go I'm
ready around ready
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
oh chili Maple you throw in the maple
just to kind of lull you into that it's
gonna be okay A little sweet Heat
[Music]
it's good the chili and the maple
so your latest movie spirited had some
huge musical moments including my
personal favorite which is based
entirely around the idea that telling
someone good afternoon was the
equivalent to telling them to f off in
Dickens era London yes what stands out
when you think about the behind the
scenes mechanics that went into the
film's particularly ambitious song and
dance numbers good afternoon is a great
example where it all came from Sean
Anders our director who was studying the
classic version of Christmas carol which
I think was shot in the 1940s or 30s and
he he was remembering how everyone in
that movie
if they said good afternoon it was as if
it was like how what did he just
say to me oh my goodness
good and it was it was the dickensian
version of Fu and we thought oh
we should do a whole song Just based off
of that phrase good afternoon and then
it's this horrible thing we're saying
and yet it's a release for my character
to kind of let off some steam are you
ready to move on here to Wing number two
number two good so this one is the
Barbacoa here in the two spot what is a
barbacoa is that like a chupacabra yeah
I think so it's a chupacabra yeah urban
legend Deep Woods
um the Barbacoa yeah coyote dog suit at
night and then breathes its hot sauce
breath on you yeah that's where it comes
from
[Music]
so far so good maybe I've gotten tougher
so as amused to read that you actually
worked as a mall Santa before your
career in comedy took off yes can you
give us one highlight and one low light
of being a Pasadena Plaza Kris Kringle
yeah I did that um in My Starving actor
days I was Santa and Chris Katan
was was my elf
Chris Kattan from Saturday Night Live
and we did Night at the Roxbury together
it was fun because we would
we would walk in a J.Crew and like I'd
be like hello J.Crew Merry Christmas
uh you know how are the button Downs
doing this and they'd all they got so
used to be like hi Santa like folding
shirts
uh do you have a houndstooth jacket
anywhere no it's in the back Santa like
they were so over us uh and we also
start we also learned that no one was
there to monitor our break times so we
would take like five minutes every hour
by the time I mean we
we take we'd work for 10 minutes and
take 50 minutes off and just another
accounting work harassing the crews at J
crew is that you counting oh yeah yeah
that's on the clock that's on the clock
that's on the clock but the worst and
best moment
was we encountered this family these two
kids came up to us to say hi
and it was right out of um the uh the
cosmetic store Origins they had this
little
um sculpture of a
of like a coyote in front of the store
and
we're saying hello to these kids
[Music]
and we look up
and it's Kevin Costner there's a parent
with them
and it's Kevin Costner with a hat he's
being very Incognito and we're like
hello what's your name oh Mary what'd
you what I've been a good little boy and
girl hi Santa hi and Kevin Costner you
know he's just kind of looking at us and
and they're crawling on this coyote
and I and I was like oh do you like
crawling on that little coyote sculpture
and then Chris can't help himself is
like
it looks like you're dancing on the cut
in fact it looks like you're dancing
with Wolves
and Kevin Costner goes
let's go let's go like don't blow my
cover
he's like okay come on kids let's go
let's go I'm like what are you doing
he's like I couldn't help it in his elf
voice
so that was like
good and bad
[Music]
I'm really proud of myself so far
[Music]
you can already tell I already smell it
[Music]
I smell the heat coming up
and then these are really good Wings
they're kind of falling off the bone but
that was one of those bites where like
it all fell off together so I felt like
I just ate
yes that entire Wing like in one bite
yeah so it's kind of leaves a little
Trail yeah
that is a jump up
we're taking exponential leaps here you
know yeah
yeah so last time you're on the show we
talked about the influence that Sports
has not only in your work but throughout
your life is someone who once held the
single season field goal record at
Irvine's University High School what is
your take on the plight of the kicker
like do you think that it's an
underappreciated position in art form
it's definitely an art form uh
I think yeah kickers will always be the
butt of many a joke on a on a football
team uh
because and I I lived it I didn't have
to run laps I didn't have to tackle
anyone or be tackled
and yet I could win a game and so
uh it's a pretty good gig right it's
pretty yeah
you don't know why you don't have to
worry about head trauma
you can just run out there you don't
even have to wear the pads in your pants
unless they're going to eliminate field
goals and extra points you got to give
you got to get more respect exactly and
then I noticed that you're wearing the
king's hoodie today yeah and when I saw
you at the Kings game last year you had
your King's chain I could tell
immediately that I was dealing with just
a seasoned sports event professional
yeah do you have an all-time favorite
Will Ferrell Jumbotron moment well there
is a video that I shot that they play
every time I'm at the game and then they
inevitably cut to me
and
something happened last year
where usually I just wave and but now I
mimic the video on the jump so I'm there
screaming
go Kings go but I've Incorporated karate
chop
so that I'm I do go Kings go go go but
I'm scree I don't know why I'm screaming
because no one can hear me I'm in a big
Stadium
but that gets that gets a really good
that gets the place going yeah gets a
place going get some people go get some
people going it's it's no one knows what
it means it gets the people going
Beyond Insanity I remember it I have
nightmares about it
cleansing breath yeah deep cleansing
breath
[Music]
if you chew it really fast does it
no I don't think there's any I don't
think that there's any trick
it's just you're there and since we've
been at the same time it's now hitting
for me I imagine across the table engage
mucous membrane
as the snot flows down yeah yeah no fun
yeah never get used to this one
so when you first joined the cast at SNL
why was it important for you to embrace
the opportunity of small roles like I've
heard you talk about getting big
reactions on just like screaming beach
volleyball off camera yeah uh
well
I have a little milk yeah yeah that's
all right
um thank you
yeah I realized
I mean I love being on site alive
because
it was my favorite show
but also being a part of an ensemble
I just loved it I I made a point
to tell the writers
I don't care Caspian in a super small
part because
some guest members took offense
and and I just made a point to say I'll
deliver a pizza in the scene you know if
you need someone just because it's
supportive but it's also just an
opportunity to potentially get a laugh
got it
serve me well
and then it's a Trope of ours to ask SNL
Alum about things going sideways during
the live tape besides flubbing literally
the first lines that you ever had on the
show what's been your most memorable
break
uh careful yeah
I saw that one tier just going
yeah
uh one
there was a great break
there was a character I had done on a
weekend update he suffered from a
disease called voice immodulation oh
shoot I might have gotten something I
was so sorry about that I was so worried
about that
I'm not a doctor
[Music]
okay
does it happen it does happen it does
happen I'm usually like right on it am I
gonna but usually it's not gonna lose my
eyesight no no you're gonna be okay
you're gonna be okay what you had his
little cross-pollination like you
probably yeah took your fingers on the
yeah cloth and then took that cloth
but anyway bear Mist yourself
this I'm just gonna keep my eyes
I uh I started doing this character and
the glasses I was wearing
fogged up so much that I couldn't see
the cue cards
and so that just started making me laugh
so hard that I totally broke
Tina and Jimmy were like Jacob are you
okay and
but I speak like this the whole time and
so it was
uh it was Insanity yeah all right well
[Music]
oh I think we're back
do I look like a prize fighter yeah yeah
just right after you just went 12 rounds
12 rounds MMA guy
well this is the last ad we called the
last dab because the tradition around
here to put a little extra on the last
Wing if you're having too many things
going on over there you don't have to oh
I'm not gonna wuss out there we go
[Music]
I can't really see it to open it it's
like the it's like the sketch all over
again it is
foreign
[Music]
I'm just gonna rub that off actually
yeah there you go all right cheers well
cheers
[Music]
all right well Barrel okay
[Music]
yeah oh I got the late I got the tag of
the
oh these are from Utah
right
[Music]
proud distinction of taking on the wings
of death on two separate occasions
reigning Victorious and in a time like
this that's all about reflection right
all about being grateful all about
giving thanks I think we need to
officially acknowledge your contribution
to the art form to those of us here at
hot ones I want to present you with the
final award thank you Dom a final award
look at the day from what I can see it's
the hot one Spirit award this is amazing
and it's all yours you can put it right
next to your Mark Twain on the mantle
yeah yeah yeah the the floor is yours
wow I just want to thank everyone here
at hot wings hot ones sorry hot ones uh
I feel like
we really become a family
in these
12 minutes or so I've been here
and uh
you know every morning I'm gonna put
this by my bedside and every morning
when I wake up I'm gonna look at it with
my one good eye
and remember
the friendship and the warmth the
literal warmth yeah of the heat the Heat
of that you and your show have shown me
so thank you so much
thank you
this is the greatest award I will ever
receive
[Music]
all right thank you so much as well
happy holidays
congratulations thank you good to see
you I'll catch you at the next Kings
game
well there you have it it's another hot
ones holiday Extravaganza in the books
will we're wishing you a very speedy
recovery on that eye and to you watching
at home we wish you happy holidays you
know this is one of our favorite shoots
of the Year Dom our producer Dom it's
her favorite shoot of the year and I
think it's because we get to spend this
special time with you guys during this
very special time so thank you so much
for watching if you're able to donate to
Common threads and one last time I'll
point it out in the corner donate common
threads common threads common threads
thank you so so much and from our family
over here at hot ones to yours watching
at home we wish you a very happy holiday
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]